tell me Tommy why are you so sure
there's a Santa Claus because my daddy
told me so here say hey legal eagles
it's time to think like a lawyer and
it's time to save Santa Claus today we
are covering the Christmas classic
Miracle on 34th Street now I may be a
jaded cynical lawyer but I love a good
holiday movie especially one that
involves lawyers saving the day because
who else is going to save Santa Claus if
not for the lawyers if you disagree with
me be sure to comment in the form of an
objection which are either sustain or
overrule and I will pin the best comment
that most thinks like a lawyer of course
stay until the end when I give Miracle
on 34th Street a grade for legal realism
and we settle once and for all the
question of whether there really is a
Santa Claus or not so without further
ado let's dig in to the original Miracle
on 34th Street
[Music]
terrible Santa Claus Oh could be public
intoxication big trouble she's a little
confused and I thought maybe you could
help to straightener I'd be glad to
would you please tell her that you're
not really Santa Claus but there
actually is no such person oh no no no
you misunderstand I want you to tell her
the truth
what's your name's Kris Kringle I'll bet
you're in the first grade second I mean
your real name that is my real name so
there is a philosophical discussion here
that this movie sort of skirts which is
what does it actually mean to be someone
what if your particular subjective
belief about your own identity doesn't
comport with what everybody else thinks
is there such a thing as a Platonic
ideal of someone's identity these are
some heady philosophical questions that
I'm not even going to try to answer but
I think we should probably keep that in
mind as we delve into a trial over one's
own personal identity now I want you to
stand with your feet together and your
arms extended you know sometimes the
cause of nervous habits like yours is
not obvious no often they're the result
of an insecurity are you happy at home
mr. Sawyer that will be all mr. pickle
the examination is over you may go I
have to believe that having an on staff
psychologist or therapist was pretty
unusual in a department store even in
the 1940s it seems kind of weird to have
someone permanently on staff who does
nothing but psychologically evaluate
your employees you're probably doing
something wrong creating a dangerous
workplace if you have to have a
psychologist on hand in your department
store it seems a little weird I thank
you your job here I understand is to
give intelligence tests pressing
yourself
psychologist you ought to be
horsewhipped taking a normal
impressionable boy like Alfred and
filling him up with complexes phobias
think I'm better equipped to judge that
than you are just because the boy wants
to be good in kind to children you tell
him he has a good compelling the same
delusion you couldn't possibly
understand the boy is definitely
maladjusted and I'm not Justin you talk
about managers seems to me that the
patient is running the clinic I won't
step leave this office immediately thurr
you stop oh he might be trespassing at
this point mr. Macy and tell him what a
malicious contemptible from what you are
get out before I have you thrown out
there's only one way to handle a man
like you you won't listen to reason your
hotness you have no humanity are you
going to leave yes oh boy I thought if
you're naughty got a lump of coal in
your stocking not bashed in the head
with a cudgel I think Santa might be in
some trouble here because he has
committed a clear-cut case of battery
battery is a simple tort that only has
two elements number one you have to have
intentional contact with a plaintiff's
body and number two that intentional
contact must produce some sort of injury
but in New York where this movie takes
place there are several different kinds
of battery including aggravated battery
so to figure out which particular
variety of battery Kris Kringle has
committed here we need to think like a
lawyer
New York has several different varieties
of assault and battery
the first of which is the least severe
which is assault in the third degree or
commonly called simple assault which is
causing someone harm with the intent to
do so it doesn't matter how severe the
injury is so long as you have caused
pain you have made physical contact with
another person without consent that is a
misdemeanor charge which is punishable
by up to a year in jail now the next
type of assault is assault in the second
degree which generally you do by again
making physical contact with someone but
with the intent to do serious bodily
harm and actually committing serious
bodily harm causing serious bodily harm
in the victim not surprisingly if you
commit second-degree assault because it
is so much more severe
carries with it a much more severe
penalty assault in the second degree is
a class D felony and carries with it a
mandatory jail sentence and then finally
there is assault in the first degree
which is the most severe form of assault
which is committed with the intent to
disfigure or amputate the victim here so
it's a very very serious penalty that
carries with it a mandatory multi year
sentence so it is a big deal but let's
put that aside for the moment and just
focus on the simple assault and
potential second-degree assault charges
against Santa Claus Kris Kringle Kris
Kringle got into a heated argument with
the fake psychiatrist after basically
yelling at each other
he picked up an umbrella a hard object
and hit the psychiatrist over the head
with it under those circumstances you
might be able to conclude that he
intended to inflict serious bodily harm
on the fake psychiatrist on the other
hand you might argue that since this is
ostensibly Santa Claus here he did not
intend to seriously injure the man but
just to ring his bell and to cause him
temporary suffering for what he has
caused the other little boy here and you
can see that the psychiatrist is not
permanently harmed and in fact
malingerers and fakes the seriousness of
his injury to get sympathy from his
co-workers which might militate in favor
of it being a non serious bodily injury
and really just being unwanted physical
contact rather than the more severe
penalties associated with assault in the
second degree however there is a
complication here because in New York if
you use a weapon it is an automatic
aggravation from simple assault to
assault in the second degree I think
there is a reasonable argument that an
umbrella especially the hard end of an
umbrella constitutes a weapon and might
take the simple assault from being
unwanted fiscal conduct into the realm
of second-degree assault which is a
Class D felony
so within the world of this movie Kris
Kringle has committed assault and may be
guilty of felony aggravated assault in
bhopping the psychiatrist on the head
with an umbrella Merry Christmas
listen I'm no legal brain trust I don't
know of habeas from a corpus but I do
know politics that's my record
I got you elected in math and I'm gonna
try to get you reelected I know Chuck
judges are elected in a lot of
jurisdictions it's a big problem
actually and I'm telling you to get off
this case but because you're a regular
punches pilot the minute you start
that's why oh I don't believe it I'm an
honest man and nobody's going to hold it
against me for doing my duty as I see it
this sort of does highlight the problems
that judges have in staying objective
there are a lot of political
consequences associated with different
outcomes and it's really difficult to
stay objective in these circumstances
taking a cigar into court boy those were
the bad old days all persons having
business with the special tongue
part 3 of the Supreme Court held in and
for the county of New York draw near and
give your attendance and you shall be
high so what's happening here is a
motion by the state to involuntarily
commit someone in elderly gentlemen in
Kris Kringle to a mental institution I
actually had to look this up because
mental illness law is not something that
I practice with any frequency and I
thought it actually might be a trope in
movies that looks good but isn't true
like quicksand for example however what
I found is that there is actually a
procedure in New York law to be able to
involuntarily commit someone for a
mental illness both in the present day
and in 1947 when this movie came out and
in fact what it requires is that the
state prove by a preponderance of the
evidence that the individual in question
suffers from a mental illness that
requires immediate inpatient care
without which it's likely to result in
serious harm to that person or others
around them so if those requirements are
met it is possible for the state of New
York to involuntarily commit someone to
a mental institution for treatment now
you know
another well man the bailiff will tackle
you before you Your Honor please I
should like to call the first witness
mr. Kringle will you take the stand his
first witness is the defendant mr.
Kringle you don't have to answer any
questions against your wishes or even
testify at all we have no objection your
honor
oh I'll be glad to answer any questions
that I can so that was a huge strategic
mistake Kris Kringle here has a Fifth
Amendment right not to testify and it's
common for a lot of people to think well
if you don't have anything to hide then
you might as well take the stand but
that is the wrong way to look at it
because everyone has testimony that may
come back to haunt them and bad things
can happen based on your own testimony
so it is especially important where the
state bears the burden of proof not to
give them ammunition and here we know
that there are skeletons in the closet
because Kris Kringle has bashed someone
over the head with the blunt end of an
umbrella he has committed assault and
it's possible he committed felony
assault against the fake psychiatrist
and in a hearing over whether you
present an immediate danger to yourself
or others that kind of testimony is
going to be very very important and in
fact that testimony alone might be
enough to meet the state's burden here
to show that he needs to be committed
involuntarily to a mental institution
where do you live that's what this
hearing will decide
very sound answer mr. krinkle the judge
should not be opining at this point you
believe that you're Santa Claus of
course but what does it mean to be Santa
Claus in a Cartesian way the fact that
he actually thinks he is Santa Claus is
a form of being Santa Claus and in fact
one who plays Santa Claus is a type of
Santa Claus perhaps a transitory or
temporary Santa Claus
I don't know that this date has made its
burden here I think it has a long way to
go and arguing both the philosophical
and legal questions here state rests
your honor mmm so at this point what
that means is that the state is not
going to put on any more witnesses and
it's not going to put forward any more
evidence the only testimony that has
come out is the testimony that's come by
way of Kriss Kringle himself which is
crazy considering that he could have put
the fake psychiatrist on the stand to
explain that he actually was physically
assaulted by Kriss Kringle
that would have gone a long way towards
meeting his burden all he has done is
asked a few questions which are
ambiguous at best to establish the
mental state of this individual person
and hasn't had any testimony that goes
to whether he is a physical danger to
himself or others so at this point I
don't think there's any argument that
the state has not made its burden I
think that maybe intentional the
prosecutor probably doesn't want to ruin
Christmas the judge doesn't want to ruin
Christmas and face the ire of his
grandchildren so I think that he is
intentionally tanking this case to not
go forward I believe he was employed to
play Santa Claus perhaps he didn't
understand the question correctly oh I
understood the question perfectly your
honor it doesn't actually solve anything
though he can understand it and the
question can still mean different things
there's no further questions at this
time
yeah there's definitely not be any
cross-examination thank you
and view of this statement do you still
wish to put in a defense young man I do
your honor
oh so what the judge is hinting at there
is that the defense should not go
forward because the state has not made
its burden instead what the defense
really should have done here is filed
for a directed verdict or a motion for
judgment as a matter of law at Jaimal
what those motions do is they signal to
the court that the person or entity that
has the burden in this case the state of
New York has not met their burden taking
the evidence and in the light most
favorable to the moving party it doesn't
rise the level of the thing that they
have to prove the state has the burden
of proof they have to prove that Kris
Kringle has a mental illness that is a
danger to himself and others they have
not met their burden it was a big
mistake by the self-proclaimed greatest
lawyer in the world to not stop this
trial right here because there's no
reason this trial should continue anyone
who thinks he's Santa Claus is not sane
not necessarily you believe yourself to
be judge Harper yeah no one questions
your sanity because you are judge Harper
I know all about myself young man all
right get metaphysical he is the person
he believes himself to be just as you
are then he's just as sane but he isn't
all but he is your honor it's what I
intend to prove that mr. Kringle is
Santa Claus that's very very amusing but
a terrible defense strategy he has now
taken on an affirmative burden which the
law doesn't put on him and he has
decided not to end this trial when it
should have been ended and decided to
prove something that he doesn't actually
have to prove not a good strategy when
you're sitting in a winning position as
a defense when the prosecution hasn't
made their case go in and get mother
scissors with you they're in the bedroom
that's a good boy I don't want to
discuss this case in front of him break
his heart but while we're on the subject
I agree with the reporters mr. Kringle
seems to be a nice old man and I don't
see
you have to keep persecuting me firstly
I am NOT persecuting him
I am prosecuting him and secondly I like
the old man to which I've never gotten
into this but it's too late now there's
nothing I can do about it
it's up to the state of New York and I'm
just their duly appointed legal
representative Kringle has been declared
a menace to society by competent doctors
and it's my duty to protect the state of
New York and see that he's put away no
matter what they may say about me I've
got to do it I think the prosecutor does
have an ethical obligation to go forward
with his case as a zealous advocate for
the state of New York but on the other
hand he also has the ability to dismiss
this case entirely and to drop the case
that I don't think the DA has to proceed
so that's an interesting ethical
quandary I'm not sure which way that
comes out in favor of the prosecutor
here I think he probably could drop it
if he wanted to
psychologist where'd you graduate from a
Correspondence School you're fired
ooh and now he has a claim for
retaliation mr. Mehra seems to have
appointed himself the judge here your
honor
he's now ruling on what testimony I'm
after - Your Honor we request an
immediate ruling from this Court is
there or is there not a Santa Clause so
I actually think that this court may be
constitutionally prohibited from
weighing in on that question because
remember Santa Claus is a religious
figure Saint Nicholas and under the
First Amendment courts cannot weigh in
on religious decisions under the United
States Supreme Court jurisprudence
specifically the u.s. versus Ballard
case that came out in 1944 just three
years before this movie did courts are
prohibited under the First Amendment
from deciding religious questions in
other words they cannot decide the truth
or falsity of any particular religious
tenets and what the Salvation Army
watching but you go ahead Henry you do
it your way you go on back in there and
tell them that you rule there's no Santy
Claus come on what if you do remember
this you can count on getting just two
votes your own and that District
Attorney's out there the judge really
shouldn't be in this situation at all
because most judges describe to the
judicial Canon that the court should
only decide the minimum number of
questions that are absolutely necessary
for the resolution of the case at hand
and here the judge doesn't actually have
to weigh in on this question the court
really should just say that the
prosecution has not met its burden not
weigh in on the larger question of
whether there is a Santa Claus or not
can he produce any evidence to support
his views if your honor please I can
well Thomas Mara please take the stand
pull me Thomas Mara Junior
they gave him a subpoena well if you're
going to call the prosecutor son you
have to subpoena them he gave me a
brand-new flexible Flyers flat last year
and what does he look like
positive ID why are you so sure there's
a Santa Claus because my daddy told me
hearsay should be objecting here also he
should be fighting like hell to prevent
his son from testifying here that's
totally improper but adorable he's a
very honest man course she is my daddy
wouldn't tell me anything that wasn't so
would you dead Thank You Tommy no
cross-examination goodbye daddy
guarana the state of new york concedes
the existence of Santa Claus that may be
an ethical issue for him right there but
he shouldn't have conceded he should
have just dropped the case there
wouldn't have been any presidential
value in this particular trial if the DA
just gave up prosecuting it and withdrew
the motion to commit the defendant here
this is a problem of their own creation
I therefore request that mr. Gailey now
submit a ferret ativ proof that mr.
Kringle is the one and only Santa Claus
that's not a legal standard there's no
such thing as authoritative proof there
is proof and you have to meet your
burden of generally speaking here proof
by preponderance of the evidence but
there's no such thing as coca Thorat
ativ proof your honor I'm sure we're all
gratified to know that the post office
Department is doing so nicely but it
hardly has any bearing on this case it
has a great deal your honor if I may be
allowed to proceed by all means mr.
Gailey Your Honor the figures I have
just quoted indicate an efficiently run
organization furthermore the United
States Postal laws and regulations make
it a criminal offence to willfully
misdirect mail or intentionally deliver
to the wrong party so there is something
called the supremacy clause in the US
Constitution that requires that where
the federal government has acted that
preempts state law contradictory action
on that particular point but on the
other hand it does create a precedence
state laws and courts rely on
regulations from the federal government
not for their preclusive effect but
often for their authority in very
different cases for example if a state
court is deciding a matter of first
impression it will often rely on federal
court decisions or administrative
decisions of the federal government in
crafting its opinion because while it's
not bound by those decisions it can use
those opinions and decisions and
regulations as persuasive Authority if
the federal government has decided
something it lends a great deal of
credence to the idea that that is what
should actually happen in a matter of
first impression before the state court
so what's happening here relying on the
post office
presumably the administrative decision
of the post office has a ring of truth
to it
state court judges do that all the time
I have further exhibits your honor but I
hesitate to produce them oh I'm sure
we'll be very happy to see them yes yes
yes produce the mr. Cady put them here
on my desk
what's your honor I put them here on the
desk yes
that's what we call the overwhelming
weight of authority all right now it's
time to give this holiday classic a
grade for legal realism it's been a long
time since I've seen this movie and I'm
delighted to see all the legal
accuracies the hearing regarding mental
commitment is both based in law and
largely factually correct the legal
arguments are inventive but somewhat
realistic however on the other side they
gloss over the fact that Santa Claus
committed assault that he waived his
Fifth Amendment rights and kind of
screwed up some of the constitutional
arguments but this is a clear holiday
classic so I'm going to give this
wonderful holiday movie three candy
canes it's so wonderful I don't see how
I can give it anything less than that
and on the question of whether there
really is a Santa Claus or not well as
an officer of the court I am bound by
Supreme Court precedents and I can't
lose my impartiality but I will say this
if the real Santa Claus is out there and
you're looking for the best attorney in
the world I will represent you pro bono
so happy holidays legal eagles and until
next time I'll see you in court